ما جذبك للقدوم إلى الشرق
الأوسط
أعتقد كرائد أعمال وكرجل
أعمال حتى قبل 20 عامًا ، كان من
الواضح أن دبي والمنطقة ككل
بدأت في التقدم في الابتكار
وريادة الأعمال وأشياء من هذا
القبيل وأنت تعرف دبي السعودية مصر  من
الواضح جدًا ما
يحدث ، لذا فإن
هدفي مع شركة الاتصالات الخاصة بي
vaynerx vaynermedia هو أن أكون في كل
جزء من العالم وكأننا نأتي
بعودة قوية تعرف 100
بالإضافة إلى الشباب بشكل عام مثل  الأشخاص الذين
تقل أعمارهم عن 35 عامًا في جميع أنحاء المنطقة يتمتعون
بذكاء اجتماعي عميق يتمتع بالذكاء التكنولوجي التقدمي ،
أعني أن هذا هو المكان الذي يوجد فيه العالم وهذا هو
المكان الذي يتجه إليه العالم ،
وبالتالي فإن الحيوية والطبيعة الهجومية
الأجنبية